also we got to talk about the Raiders as
they are preparing to come to town as
our Raiders day here fan day at 8 News
now we have some big announcements on
the horizon but first let's get to Nate
Tannenbaum outside in the Sun talk more
about football and the weather hey Nate
hey John yeah we're out here with the
Raiders firetruck which was purchased
about four years ago by the laborers
Union we'll talk more about that but we
want to talk now about the excessive
heat warning so we're showing you a
Legion stadium and we're in the mid 90s
already on our way to what could be a
record high first we'll start with an
excessive heat warning that started at
10:00 this morning scheduled to run
until 8:00 Friday evening for all of
Southern Nevada parts of Southern
California and Northwest Arizona as well
now as we move on and show you the
satellite picture not much to show just
high pressure very much in control so
your weather headlines go like this we
do have the excessive heat warning
through Friday we may be in for some
record temperatures but there are some
changes coming up over the weekend we'll
talk about that in a few minutes John